which countries get the best night's
sleep we developed the LIE index to
track the variation in sleep patterns
across the world the worst sleepers are
mainly in Asian countries per week night
Japan South Korea and India average just
over 6 hours whereas in northern
European countries like Finland Ireland
and the Netherlands people log a solid 7
hours a night as they do in Australia
and New Zealand lack of sleep is a
serious business staying up for 20 hours
has the same effect on your reasoning as
drinking a bottle of wine and one study
found lack of sleep cost Japan nearly 3%
of its annual GDP largely due to lower
productivity what time people hit the
sack and get up in the morning also
varies by country South Africans go to
bed earliest before 11:00 while Japan
and Russia have some of the latest bed
times turning in after midnight but in
Japan people are up nearly an hour
earlier than in Russia researchers think
these variations could be connected to
work culture and as 2 weeks of 6our
nights has the same effect on your brain
as pulling two consecutive all nighters
it's a good idea to try to get the
lights off
earlier